[موسيقى]
نحاولنا خلال الحروب كلها
في تلك الفتره
ان نقنع المجتمع الدولي وفي المقدمه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان هناك
يوافق امريكا الى صنعاء كلنا نسلم
ادي لك قصه جانا
الجنرال ماتش الذي كان قائد القوات
المركزيه حين هذه 2010
جاءنا الى صنعاء وكان التقيت به عملت لهم
عزومه غداء وكنا في نادي ضباط الجيش
المسلم
ولكن دائما يقولون ان الادله غير كافيه
ممكن يكون دلتكم
قلت له ما رايك انا اسلمك الان ملف وهذا
يمكن الملف 20 قال لي شوف لا تتعب نفسك
ان هذه جماعه تتبع ايران ومدعومه من ايران
ولكن من يقنع البيت الابيض
هذا في عام 2010
[موسيقى]
البحث يعتقد على ان هذه الميليشيات بدات
فقط
[موسيقى]
الخلايا الايرانيه بدات تتشكل في اليمن
في عام 83 بالتجامل مع تكوين حزب الله في
لبنان
وكان على راس هذه المجموعه
بدر الدين الحوثي ابو عبد الملك
وليته صلاح فليته اللي ابو محمد هذا اللي
يسميه المتحدث الرسمي
كانوا هم المسؤولين عن هذه الخلايا
وقاموا بعمليات ارهابيه في صنعاء
قنابل على سينما بلقيس وقتل الحارس
السينما في تلك الفتره
واعمال اخرى ارهابيه
وتم ضبطهم وسجنهم وبعضهم هربوا الى ايران
ثم عاد ببساطه حينها مع الحكومه في عام 86
[موسيقى]